I only found this out recently as you
almost quit after your first week so my
first and I tell people this all the
time I interview my first week here I
was like yeah cuz I wasn't stand-up I
was used to going to bed at 7 in the
morning and not being at work at 7
anymore on that right so I was like yo I
can't do this man waking up every
morning and coming here whatever and it
was you have Chris Hayes and Erica that
worked as she's a secretary chris is the
IT guy both of them black and came into
my office and he was like this he was
the IT guy he was like this hey I come
to come fix your computer and uh we're
black people about to say some racist
they look over they show the before this
computer you go make black people proud
in there
[Applause]
and I was like you know you can't do
that to me and then about an hour later
Erica came in there so it's like Heidi
on here's your business cards please go
make us proud in it I can see I could
see this happen Erica no you're not
gonna put this pressure on me and then I
was like forget it man and I just kept
writing and write and none of my writing
was working then one day they was
writing the sketch on Andy right there
the sketch called it's called
Oktoberfest and I didn't know what the
hell Oktoberfest was right I was like
what the hell does Oktoberfest famous I
always did German drinking day we're
gonna do this bit with Andy I was like
Germans Ricky dates whatever it was like
what I'm saying everybody got a drinking
day Germans
Mexicans got Cinco DeMayo uh Irish got
st. Patty's Day why they know black
drinking day yeah Mike Sweeney was like
write it up
I was like okay well I don't know what
to do this I will show you what to do
and we wrote it up and then there's like
Conan Conan said that's funny
you're gonna go say it on stage I was
like what and I went out and I did it
and the next thing I know the TV guy
said a star was born
Jackie Robinson we're so happy for you
just thrilled for all your success you
deserve it I want to say something from
the bottom of my heart I would not be
here if it was not for calling it aching
now let me taste them about calling a
real quick and I'm sorry from going over
my time but no Conan is a guy that
doesn't do things traditionally he
doesn't kind of kind of gotta sit back
and look at your resume and uh let me
see what you're doing - what you bout
and what you've done and AH dag cone is
the kind of guy like real men do he sit
back with you and he talked to you and
he see what kind of guy you are he hire
you just like that
I never submitted a script I never wrote
nothing and he liked it it was never
none of that
it was strictly me and him talking like
man and having a good time and he went I
want higher and higher me and I think
the same thing happen with you because I
did research on that right writing pie I
don't know I didn't have a writing
packet not before we met we did yeah we
met and we just hit it off yeah we
headed off we had lunch and we hit it
off and I went to City Roberts Amaro I
want to hire him and he said well he
really should submit a writing packet
like all right have him write a writing
packet I guess but we're hiring him well
that's the beauty that's the beauty of
feeling just vibing with people
everything don't have to be
traditionally done you can't put
traditional you can't put extraordinary
people with traditional boxes and this
man right here
yes returns to ABC October 16th to 9:00
p.m. hey you i Deon Cole you love the
unpro you want to go see Dionne Cole
November 15th through the 18th at DC
improv Deon Cole back
[Applause]
you